l'information du jour c'est donc
l'annoncé d'une nouvelle manifestation
des opposants au mariage pour tous
nouvelle manifestation nationale contre
le projet de loi prévue le 26 mai alors
que le sénat a adopté hier soir un
article qui supprime l'exigence de la
différence des sexes comme conditions du
droit au mariage c'est le premier
article de cette réforme
le sénat doit achever vendredi ou samedi
l'examen complet du texte une fois voté
par le sénat il reviendra en seconde
lecture devant les députés probablement
à la fin mais on écoute
à ce sujet la réaction de philippe
brillault le maire ump des yvelines de
duchesnay pardon conseiller général des
yvelines il espérait mieux lui qui mène
depuis plusieurs mois la contestation
est interpellé par le score c'est à dire
que la différence entre les pour et les
contres m'a paru plus important que ce
que l'on aurait pu attendre en fonction
de ce qu'on pille et les sénateurs sur
le sujet voilà donc on s'interroge
effectivement sur un vote plus politique
que une liberté de personnes sur le
sujet il faut qu'on mobilise très fort
dès aujourd'hui les gens colonies c'est
celui ci met pour permettre au président
hollande de se donner un petit peu de
temps pour repasser à l'assemblée
nationale le texte
voilà parce que oh sees the au conseil
économique et social on attend en
octobre les conclusions de
l'auto-saisine sur le sujet qui aborde
un peu le thème de la famille moi je
pense qu'il faut que le président
hollande donne un tout petit peu de
temps la précipitation pour passer à
l'assemblée nationale va mettre le feu
au pays le mois de l'efva est un mois à
très haut risque pour lui là vraiment on
a tous les ingrédients du mai 68 ça
c'est clair
et puis toujours à propos du mariage
homosexuel cet article publié sur le
site du nouvel observateur
hier lundi 2 lundi en début de semaine
qui continue à faire parler un couple
homosexuel agressé violemment à paris et
qui témoigne photo à la pluie ce qui
arrive est liée à la façon dont le débat
se déroule dit l'un d'entre eux avant
d'ajouter a bien sûr ce n'est pas henri
guaino qui m'a tabassé le député des
yvelines a réagi ce matin sur les ondes
d'europe 1 il n'a pas mâché ses mots que
le nouvel observateur que le journaliste
et le journal qui donne des leçons à
tout le monde et publié sur son site
quand l article est une abjection elle
des propos d'henri guaino c'était ce
matin je vous propose d'écouter
l'intégralité de sa réaction ce matin
sur europe 1 un échange menées par bruce
toussaint on écoute alors moi je veux
bien que les deux jeunes victimes de
ceux de cet attentat abominable à
personne ne peut approuver ni même
excusé et ni vu ni rester indifférent à
ces ascètes à ce qui s'est passé je
ils sont sous le coup de l'émotion mais
que le nouvel observateur que le
journaliste et le journal qui donne des
leçons à tout le monde et publié sur son
site un tel article est une abjection
voilà le journaliste est abject le
journal étape oui mais je veux finir on
entendu cette injection de cette
abjection la com de ce que fait le
président la république en jetant
l'opprobre sur les hommes politiques
comme de ce que fait le juge a été abus
de pouvoir vous savez ce que ça crée de
cette abjection n'est toujours le
fascisme